let's start first with help everyone
understand your background and kind of
the origin story of bitcoin beach for
those that don't know
yeah so i wound up in el salvador about
17 years ago on a surf trip and fell in
love with the country and talked my wife
and buying a place here and about eight
years ago we moved to el salvador and
just saw a lot of the needs in our
community and around the country and so
we started investing in different
projects
and just kind of especially focusing on
al zante where we're at and two years
ago it kind of combined my love for
bitcoin with uh
the needs of the unbanked here and just
seeing how bitcoin could truly change
their lives even much more than it's
changed my life and so about two years
ago we started uh pushing bitcoin out
into the community through
um incentivizing kids to get good grades
um doing different work in the community
a lot of things really focused on
keeping them out of gangs gangs have
have historically been a big issue in el
salvador and so um we never envisioned
it taking off into something that would
change the world's monetary system but
it's been yeah it's been a crazy ride
and when you think about those early
days of starting bitcoin beach um
what was the response did people look at
you like you were crazy did it strike
immediately people were like oh yeah
this makes sense let me start using it
like what was the reaction
both when you talked to the adults they
looked at you like you were crazy you
know people people my age you know
looked at it like this is insane like
what do you mean how do we touch a
bitcoin what do you mean no government
backs it um you know they wanted to be
able to physically hold it and so it was
really a challenge for them but when we
switched to focusing on the youth for
them it was normal they're used to
living in a digital world they're used
to transacting digitally so for them it
made sense that money would be digital
and that it would be decentralized and
so
they were kind of the ones that taught
their parents
kind of like i have to have my kids help
me set up my iphone every time there's a
new uh version released
they have helped their their parents and
grandparents come along and start using
bitcoin and once they do it a few times
they realize especially using the
lightning network and some of the newer
wallets that are out there just how easy
it is and so at first it's daunting but
quickly they get over that
yeah and today if you had to describe uh
kind of the pervasiveness of this and
the sentiment just in elizante what
exactly
is the current state of everything
obviously jack mullers peter mccormick a
bunch of other bitcoiners have gone down
and
spent some time with you in the work
that you're doing but how would you
evaluate where you are right now
i'd say we're still definitely in the
early innings um we have the vast
majority of people in el zante have have
at least used bitcoin in some fashion
probably about half of them use bitcoin
you know pretty regularly you know
weekly
um a lot of them daily a lot of them are
earning their wages in bitcoin uh
definitely a lot of them are saving in
bitcoin and so i i
i'd say probably definitely more than
anywhere else in the world any other
community the the penetration of bitcoin
is probably 10 times you know the next
highest place
as it is here in el zante so it's been a
lot of fun just seeing the network
effects kick in and how real those are
when most people in the united states or
north america uh kind of the developed
world think of bitcoin usually they
actually think of it as an investment
asset something that they buy it goes up
in dollar value maybe they sell it maybe
they hold it but it's very much an
investment not so much a currency my
understanding of what's happening in el
zante is the exact opposite most people
don't look at it as an investment but
more so they look at it as a currency a
medium of exchange is that an accurate
portrayal or what what is kind of the
balance between maybe an investment
perspective versus a currency as a like
a medium of exchange
i mean people definitely look at it as
both it's definitely a long-term savings
vehicle for a lot of them but it's
probably the inverse to that percentage
outside of alzheimer's you know most
people are like 80 focused on bitcoin as
digital gold and 20 focused on on the
you know using it as a transactional
money where in el zante i'd say it's the
reverse the eighty percent of the value
comes from the transactionalness of it
and twenty percent from the you know
long term and might no number go up
and so i think a lot of people don't
realize
you know the vast majority of the world
doesn't have access to things like cash
app or venmo or those sorts of things so
for them even moving a small amount of
money can be a huge headache long bus
rides
expensive and so anything from trying to
send twenty dollars to you know your
relative across the country to
you know for myself trying to buy a
vehicle here it's a major hurdle to get
money into the country and to move it
and bitcoin just kind of breaks down all
those barriers what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're gonna be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]